what's up everybody uh this is flagrant
two
it is
uh is that how i usually start the
podcast it's more like uh what's up
everybody welcome to flagrant two okay
okay what's up everybody welcome to
flagrant two's your boy schultzy uh
akash is not here but we have something
to represent him in spirit yes his new
religion hit it out oh you already hit
it that's brilliant okay uh we also got
alex media mark gagnon the truffles in
the building uh we even got valentifty
in the background right there and um
listen let's start we got a lot of
things to talk about first of all
charlotte thank you so much for
everybody who came out charlotte's in
hope city you had fun at charlotte it
was amazing yeah it was cool yeah it was
good you know who's a funny stand-up
comedian tell me ryan davis yeah
brian dave who al thought was haha david
cause i won't put you on black no you
will put yourself in there you're
actually you're gonna do it you're gonna
do that do it there hey mark yeah he
literally goes he he goes he goes yo hot
davis he goes he kind of looks like he
gained a little weight or something like
that i'm like yo this guy is wow
you're welcome
yeah i know it was him yeah i actually
thought it was
this cool had a 20-minute conversation
with him and then when he left the room
i was like yo who is that he's like yo
that's haha david
i was like oh [ __ ] that's how i kept
calling him
i kept calling him
he thought i was laughing like i'd be
like
you want to do some time or whatever
like that and then he would just be like
yeah sure i'll do it and then i i
realized it was actually
[ __ ] up you thought obviously i'm
teasing i know the difference i'm a
comedian but you wouldn't
but the worst person was volleyball
because when he got off stage she was
like yo earthquake is
hilarious [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
[Music]
in all seriousness uh there's a lot of
guys who are on instagram and they get
famous for doing comedy on instagram and
then they try and even girls as well
they try to translate that to the stage
and it's not there
ryan davis
is a [ __ ] stand-up comedian
he's nice he is funny funny like
like structure jokes everything there's
a lot of guys who have a lot of charisma
personality and then they bring it to
stage and it's it's not the same
stand-up is not the same than being
funny on a podcast stand up is not the
same as being just like funny hanging a
group of friends it is a different
[ __ ] beast a different skill set
different animal and and ryan davis is
funny yeah and then we were bullying his
ass we just put out some [ __ ] stand
up already like because he's in there
like hey these people don't know i do
stand up it's like well yeah
you don't tell him you do stand up you
don't show him that you do the [ __ ]
stand up but uh but that kid is funny
man yeah shout out to ryan bro shout out
to ryan that's funny and you were [ __ ]
up
you were [ __ ] up
nah you are [ __ ] up
you are [ __ ] up how you talked to him
for 20 minutes and thought it was
crawford son
yo
the disrespect literally there was a
point where he was like you were like
listen i'm not trying to fan out or
whatever but like i'm a huge fan of
breaking bad and i just thought that you
absolutely
and it was just disrespectful some march
young actually was like yo the king's a
comedy huh
you're calling birdie parties
i've already been dead
he said i'm not scared of you
that's bernie mac i just assumed
no but i do love that guy on the daily
show he was sick
on the daily what on the daily show ryan
davis he's on the daily show he's only
correspondence yo my bad that is i don't
know it's roy wood jr
go check out ryan davis man for real and
check out haha davis check out all the
davises bro real talk shout outs to the
day every comment we just said is fire
so you gotta check them out
maybe not everyone but
might have a couple dads but we out here
in the world um listen uh like i said
akash had to do a sunday show and then
we had to record early this is not on
akash uh it's not occupation
just whatever you want keep doing it
and if you're listening right now uh but
the people in the video are getting a
different job yeah
it's like a memorial it's like he passed
away i don't like this he didn't not yet
i think the plane landed but uh
are you adjusting it
man come on
damn bro bro look at that he's trying to
kill him he's trying to kill the ball
that's disrespectful that's super
disrespectful part of his name i like
how you're keeping it in the center wide
cam as if we need to be in a ceremony
[Laughter]
yo
uh i think we need to do a little
celebration
yes the boys
the boys and girls brought it home yeah
you also you need to apologize uh-huh
yeah thank you for saying that nice
dream
on that picture
of that [ __ ] you didn't think so you
didn't think so you didn't think i
didn't even know how to do it
you always add the m if it's after two
yeah ah yeah
no you gotta apologize though seriously
what yeah the women's basketball team
yeah why you've talked crazy [ __ ] about
women's basketball in your time is that
true or false that's true
it's not like they were playing man mark
if they were playing men and they beat
the men i would apologize but they were
playing women japanese women and if
there's one sport we should beat them at
i mean where height is advantage yeah
that's true also are they allowed to run
full steps or did they just do the
little pitter patter
when they're playing basketball did they
do that
can they even do like between the legs
or crossover with a little bit of
just lego motions
dude do they walk in claymation
oh what no they're slinging blocks
silently
they are silent they're silent they're
they're they're quick they're agile yeah
but their layup lines look like
celebrity deathmatch bro it's
unbelievable but you got to watch the
game did you guys watch the game nah oh
dude it was amazing
wait
you didn't there's no way
i did watch no you didn't they thought
brittany griner was a tentacle and then
they just started inserting her to
different parts of their body look at
her dreadlocks
the dreadlocks they got so turned on
they're just grabbing them trying to jam
them down their throats and stuff it was
crazy and that's why we won gold that
being said who do i need to apologize to
so you've got potters of women's
basketball in general and also women's
volleyball women's sports no yeah i
always said women's volleyball is more
lit than what than the men's wait what
because they got the fatter dumpers
i actually don't know though i think
most guys on the on the volleyball team
have bigger assets
which that is suspected of you guys if
you were an ass guy yeah you just like
the biggest ass
pointed us i know
[Music]
no but you guys if you're in the ass and
you want the biggest ass that's suspect
if you like tits only girls like the
average girl is bigger tits than the
average guy
so if you like ass if you like big ass
you should watch men's volleyball
he's saying that we should just like the
biggest asses what he doesn't realize is
that women's asses are bigger than men's
i don't think so i think on average men
have bigger assets
not even close they don't not even close
women have way fatter asses they need to
have fatter asses sitting around all the
time doing goddamn nothing for the last
million years while men built this
[ __ ] society that we live in and
flourish within
okay
yeah i guess i'm biased all right my
fault why why are you biased because i
got the dumper
yeah but you're a rarity dude and you
work on your legs you work on your quads
oh yeah shout out to the guy who's the
guy that follows me
oh uh justin medeiros yo shout out to
dustin moderos uh crossfit yeah champion
legend congratulations bro you listen to
flagrant two follow mark it will make
his day bro he will let you clap them
cheeks he's bragging about right now he
was so excited
you know it is cause mark does crossfit
in every city that we go to yeah that's
true around the world no loyalty sen
what do you mean no loyalty to your
local crossfit gym you're just handing
them cheeks out everywhere we go
i got to spread the love yeah you are
spreading out i'm spreading it all over
i'm spreading it
uh pull that up shortly yeah it's like
wearing boxers out here thigh meat
looking precious
look at supplements yeah real tall
looking massive and breathable bro yeah
yo you are looking for a readable dog
[Applause]